l'ombre il a sauvé des vies en pleine
lumière aloïs dante di frère alfred
préfère rester modeste sur le plateau
des dossiers de l'écran il raconte son
affectation à la prison du bordiot de
bourges trente ans plus tôt comme
infirmier de l'armée allemande et
j'étais parfaitement satisfaits
d'avoir été appelé à ce poste à ce
service et que j'ai pu aider ces pauvres
gens c'est pourquoi j'ai pu j'ai fait
tout ce que j'ai pu et je regrette
seulement aujourd'hui de n'avoir pu
faire davantage
surnommé le franciscain de bourges le
moine soldat se met au chevet des
prisonniers de la gestapo il est soigné
les réconforter dès lors le frère alfred
entre en résistance cette habitante de
bourges se souvient d'un homme généreux
il avait une dent contre toutes ses
supérieurs collègues tous
pendant la guerre c'est un traître
c'était dur pour lui d'assumer
il a fait de bon coeur enfin parce que
c'était dans sa nature et dirigeants et
des emprises on est dehors
en jouant les intermédiaires entre les
détenus et leurs familles et la
résistance à l'époque à cet emplacement
la boutique d'un négociant en vins
servait de plateforme de courrier
clandestins il est remettait
discrètement à monsieur des charges qui
lui même lui rendait le courrier inverse
qu'il avait reçu par la famille ni par
les amis en france on pouvait rentrer en
contact avec les prisonniers finalement
ils avaient des nouvelles d'abord de
ceux qui étaient incarcérés de ceux qui
n'étaient plus parce qu'ils avaient été
fusillés samoussy et qu'alfred pouvait
savoir parce qu'il savait pas tout non
plus loin à la fin de la guerre lemoine
est arrêté à la frontière franco
allemande puis incarcéré aux états unis
la résistance obtiendra sa libération en
1946 selon ses volontés il repose
aujourd'hui aux côtés de ses amis
berullier au cimetière de saint
doulchard